see if the wolves can't get off one
final cool book here close the quarter
rose in traffic and a blocking one the
quarter Derrick Rose he gets into the
paint is able to finish though we are we
gonna see a gate games where teams are
half of their shots are coming from
outside oh my goodness Derrick Rose that
was ridiculous let's try again here we
go oh that was sweet
yes there grows chicks gonna work on
Wiggins kicks it out hits Derrick Rose
in the back Rose finally comes up with
it coast-to-coast in the finish so
willing to shoot that mid-range shot the
biggest drops in ball screen actions
he's very good at it
Derrick Rose was getting some boos and
ahhs out of the crowd Rose finds ties
chill out corner three goodness having a
little one on it but couldn't get it but
Tyus Jones he's wide open in the corner
by the Indiana bench quad contusion that
he endured the other night and the
Timberwolves run over Indiana
karl-anthony towns set up beautifully
nice dish by Derrick Rose and you've got
to know if your man just rolling and
some wood takes it you got to take that
person's man as Taj Gibson gets two more
points get to where he wants to it's the
second time Derrick will take on the Los
Angeles Lakers and you think about
JaVale McGee and what he's done for the
lake
quick outlet and water Fox and other
stuff
where's the spin we'll get some oohs and
ahhs Toliver predict grows out of the
corner and it's a new crook to have a
game like this 50 points against a good
team for action no rebound trapped down
by Rubio Engels will fire for three that
won't drop another rebound Exim has it
blocked in the corner by who else 10
2011 MVP rose to my estimation he's not
been convicted of anything and but what
he is is it heartbeat plays hard once
again looking to push Nikki couldn't
handle the pass Derrick Rose all alone
down the other end and that's what I'm
talking about like that's not looking
small that's a bad pass by Alonzo ball
we played 65 games he had a bunch of
them did not play coach's decision
Wiggins tries again hits again Wiggins
is I'm here in the first half 5 of 7
from the field the game's leading scorer
with 13 pouring asleep think I can do
that
every strip down rose reverse nice
hesitation moves and Rose has 14 points
to the Ingram
this guy here Wiggins has been very
quiet secondhand what do you have in
first half 17 and Rose hits another
three another 3 for Derrick Rose the
largest lead of the game for the Lakers
James harassing Williams
roast reporter got it Tarek were novels
these sets of seven from downtown and
it's back to four this just in a rolls
is still a roles their roles back
[Applause]
roll step smacked again flex it in
Everett Rose makes it a one-point game
at the back threes puts the Wolves back
in this ballgame top shots rolled and
that Derrick Rose takes it away numbers
for Minnesota
Rose turning on the Jets with the finish
put it on the floor against Gibson
Derrick Rose takes the basketball away
and then grows hustling up the floor
able to get it to roll and makes most of
changes up between his legs and Derrick
Rose's shrinking the floor getting into
advantageous position that helped his
teammate out and he gets the steal end
and finish that's how you use your body
to get between the basketball and the
defender too young for that
I know buffer okay I mean I can't say
that I'm rocking it
and I'm on the road it's bad to play
lynnster in on the play levels in the
early going nearly 47% towns rose is off
the pitch like tired of search still if
Justin Koch he was not even played in
this game Derrick Rose gets that to go
he dribbled himself into space didn't
eat him touch not only you caught up
with the team and your practice but also
get caught up off the court as well
right see that's how you will late
that's in the second foul on the road by
Beasley but that's how you put pressure
on there you collapsed sharks contact as
he gets it to go at a three-point
opportunity for the holidays arch has
nine points in the game what a feed by
Derrick Rose talked about getting in the
third quarter the importance of
Minnesota's bench coming in and giving
them a shot the arm with Derrick Rose
and Dario searches sharukh puts it on
the deck
Rose steps into a three we promised
earlier in the game it's time for the
Miller line hope you know be that clear
that the opposing players just does not
like playing against Rose three
Derrick Rose has been door from downtown
Murray car race head would get back to
your own and the temple forced to turn
go home with the bus and that really was
the story of the third quarter here
sweetie contente came out were able to
dominate goodness what a finished dinner
crumbles explosive play getting up and
they just taking two defenders on right
there and winning didn't miss do is like
an iron buyer out there I mean he could
just make shots and was so consistent in
college as Derrick Rose gets to the rim
gets the hoop and the harm
20:40 game last fall was not Robin Lopez
and it may have just picked up another
and he's really assess it to it is on
what both pads and it's going to be in
hand one for Derrick Rose Baines who
sets a really nice screen open up floor
for Jason tater nice pass by Rose the
bounce pass to town
[Applause]
nice little pass by there grows through
the [ __ ] pocket passion ich two losses
this year when they lead going to the
fourth timbrels hoping to move both
those numbers to three and Derrick Rose
gets the quarter started off on the
right foot as we go under four minutes
Rose if the tip rolls back in this game
our Miller Lite hold true moment
courtesy of Derrick Rose and the
Timberwolves right now back with in for
the downtown Minneapolis
[Music]
roast it's a hand and it takes it away
in the calm that takes the ball from
Spitz his hand right in there as he's
trying to cross over on it it gets it
over to Todd's kitchen he was done with
body-contact babies Rose gets into the
paint dumps it off Kourtney J - the way
Derrick Rose again finds Gorgui Dieng
inside trying to get their third win
here Jim since the George W Bush
administration
ball game against Milwaukee where he had
11 points not nearly that already here
tonight the Bulls forced to turn over
Wiggins attacking he changing direction
at Durant that was nasty
and a really good volume player for the
Golden State Warriors hasn't he max ich
liebe there's also a veteran guy leave
most missed a few games being hurt this
year Rose said again all good friends
with a steal somebody rose and the
quarters a good choice d'Arnaud can you
can give Dario post apoplexy Evans gets
out there they're firing out and they
are giving it to test not just a hard
shot by Derrick Rose lineup combination
standpoint is Minnesota's enjoyed help
that's been a great day Derrick Rose
waits for the for fbp he's shooting 50%
from the floor he shooting close to 50%
from the three since the trade I'm
talking about abuse if you take the
entire seat
grows one another shot by Rosie this
continues to make those shots look easy
Rose pulls up overgrip it makes it in
unbelievable
roses this shot can I Griffin change his
direction wild shot won't drop Griffin
with a rebound
Timberwolves get a steal nine seconds
coming ten yes the fadeaway jump shot no
good Zach came in averaging 24 points
per game Rose off the dribble and off
the glass what a nice touch and finish
from Derrick Rose in a different mode so
to speak he's a good basketball player I
think that he betrayed him
he's got value good hands by Derrick
Rose to get
steel Mountain will convert on the other
end nearly lost the dribble
who's done this great dog over Derrick
Rose
thing of beauty over the floor and he's
taking this on as a challenge and don't
say thank you very much for that easy
bucket College is five for five and
Derrick Rose just took contact out of
three a good way to get back into the
game Taj Gibson give it kid Bazemore the
business that time in transition trying
to keep him from getting out - Derrick
Rose rose stops a bridge a renegade
matchup could be an issue tonight and
he's got little points remain Derrick
Rose now has Tani's one point away from
10,000 first career five seconds Rose
it's three back
Rosen
and really saw hey this guy's gonna have
an impact in this league and he has his
talents finally gets on the board San
Antonio has made its last six shots
Gibson with an answer not surprisingly
it's Derrick Rose right elves had some
open looks he's got to knock him down
got hit as he put it up chance from the
three-point plateful rose through a
believable I've also been actually TJ
Warren steps up and again extend that
hand and the shooting motion takes the
hand deserves to be an all-star he
certainly is tonight again mano a mano
right there I mean you're talking about
Mikael bridges their best individual
defender if he's got to be feeling a
little bit shell-shocked here on this
road trip because Moscow ciacco
hit the game-winner against him in
Toronto more than anybody else on the
floor
pancham pancham actually ten rebounds
now he's already got a double-double
with protein and tan
Derrick Rose people got a match up there
crows takes the basketball away from Lou
Williams Gibson around montrezl harrell
by the way we talked about the Clippers
how they get to the free-throw line at
lunch in the other side of it too is you
get guys in foul trouble as rows
underneath and it's a tie game that time
rows across midcourt looks up at the
clock Derrick Rose and how about Rose
another bucket here the t-wolves can
start breathing a little bit easier
Rose crosses over and he's able to get
it at the expense of montrezl harrell 15
to 2 sprint here
Rose
top punch NBA player but he's found a
home here your roses take warm for their
grows six rebounds three assists and
diving to the floor for loose balls tear
grouse takes it away he's got Knox to
team
so that does gamble a little bit that's
a calculated gamble and two off the ball
steal by Derrick Rose and then turns it
into two points and in between defenders
do you know what I mean it's a great way
to put it gross and Rosie Monroe figures
Timberwolves have the lead still 2.8
seconds to go
and then up taking lead into the house
Rose stops gets it to drop and one
Ferdie rose at the end of three the flip
side of that for the Milwaukee Bucks
when they trail going to the fourth they
are 4:30
[Applause]
[Music]
rose attacking Parker and Terra
rose with a chance for the end one he
goes into double figures technically he
was traded to the pelicans and then he
was waived dated Kate of Bates beyond
just a nice cut from Cato temple was
fortunate to come up with it it didn't
touch rim however got to get a shot up
Rose gets it up gets it down and will
add to the free-throw line quickly takes
shooter off the bounce so it tries to
come and help just into following in the
process it gets kind of a list of
company that includes lucha [ __ ] and
includes Rudy Gobert Derrick Rose out of
the timeout able to get it back to
two-point game
open the fact they've got a great
broadcast crew Brooklyn coming into play
tonight with the seventh seed in the
East Rose and we are tied for the second
time today
d-rose did what would Minnesota P
without him each and every day
stop Brooks using a timeout what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content